MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this video, we want to
look at experimental studies
of neutrino oscillations.
The first question is, where
do we get the neutrinos?
How do we produce the neutrinos?
The answer is, there's
numerous sources for neutrinos.
You might be lucky and find
them in supernova explosions.
Or if we're really
trying hard, we
can observe them as
relics of the Big Bang.
There is a lot of neutrinos
as a relic of the Big
Bang around us.
Problem is that they
have very low energies
and are difficult to observe.
Easier-- so is the use of
neutrinos in the-- generated
in cosmic ray showers.
There's a lot of neutrinos
coming from the sun.
Beams, beamlines--
accelerators can
be used to smash
particles into a material,
and then in the decay product,
produce also neutrinos.
And also, reactors.
Nuclear reactors can be
used as neutrino sources.
By the way,
neutrinos can also be
used in order to monitor
the nuclear activity
around the globe.
OK.
Studies of neutrino
oscillations.
So we can make this table here
and ask ourselves, what kind
of-- the experimental
parameters are
the length, the energy, and the
sensitivity to a specific mass
range.
So for the solar
neutrinos, you know
the distance between
the Earth and the sun
is pretty much fixed
to first order.
The energy of the
neutrinos coming out
is in the order of 1 meV.
We are going to
look at the table.
And so the mass range you can
probe is 10 to the minus 10
in delta m squared.
For atmospheric
neutrinos, they're
produced in the
upper atmosphere, 10
to the 4, 10 to 7 meters.
Energies can range--
have a large range,
let's say 10 to the
2 to 10 to the 5 meV.
And then reactors,
typically meV range.
It's kind of the nuclear range
for the neutrino energies.
And the range is
given by how much
space do you have around or
away from a nuclear reactor.
Similarly for accelerators.
You build an accelerator or
use an existing accelerator,
and then you build your
detectors, maybe close to it,
and maybe another one far away.
And that's limited by
the size of our planet
or wherever you want to
build your detectors.
Energy ranges there
depends on the energy
range of the accelerator.
And that is in the order of
10 to the 3, 10 to the 4 meV.
So you see that it's actually
rather a straightforward study.
Also, it's interesting
to see-- and we'll
see this next-- what kind
of flavor of neutrinos,
and whether or not we
can study neutrinos
or antineutrinos with other
experiment is important.
Let's go through this.
So it's been a little bit
of a history in how this all
occurred.
So the first question is, what
happens to the solar neutrinos?
So solar neutrinos
are basically produced
in the core of the sun,
together with light.
It turns out that
the light of the sun
takes about 10,000 years
to come out of the sun,
while the neutrinos
come out immediately.
So when first experiments tried
to observe solar neutrinos,
they had to theoretically
estimate how many neutrinos
to expect, and they saw less.
And so one explanation would
have been, or could have been,
or was, maybe something
happened at the core of the sun
and we just haven't seen it
yet, because the light which
come out of the sun has a
delay of up to 10,000 years.
That didn't turn
out to be the case.
So here is the spectrum
of the neutrino energies
and the specific sources
of neutrinos from the sun.
In our nuclear
physics discussion,
we'll get to the point that we
understand how the neutrino--
how the sun produces energy,
and then some of this
becomes more clear.
The story to take
away at this point
is that there are certain--
there's several processes in
the sun producing neutrinos.
And they all come with
their characteristic energy
distribution.
But the bottom line is you
find meV scale neutrinos
from the sun.
There's a soup of
electron neutrinos.
They start interacting
with the sun.
And there's a little bit of
a flavor evolution within--
when they go through
the material of the sun.
But, you know, what
you want to really do
is look for disappearance
in detectors
which are sensitive
to electron neutrinos.
And that has been done in
a number of experiments.
Most famous may be the
Davis experiments which
had a big tank of chlorine.
And in the interaction,
you were looking
for finding argon
in your detector,
and you just every now
and then went in there
and saw how much argon
was actually produced.
And it turned out that those
experiments, all of them,
found a reduced number of
neutrinos, reduced with respect
to the theoretical expectation.
So far so good.
The assumption was that--
or there was no knowledge of
neutrino oscillations or mixing
at this time.
So that needed to be explained.
And one way to explain--
it's not just using the
charge interaction, which
allows you to probe the
flavor of the neutrino,
but also lose a neutral--
the neutral
scattering, which then
allows you to measure the
total number of neutrinos.
And if you do this-- this was
done by the SNO experiment--
you find that the total
number of neutrinos
is in good agreement with
the theoretical expectation.
Hence, those neutrinos
are not really lost,
they're just more from
one flavor into the next.
So this was the first
evidence for solar neutrinos
to be oscillating.
By now there's-- this first
experiment was Homestake.
By now, there is a larger number
of solar neutrino experiments,
and you see the long
time of neutrino studies.
Different materials are
being used, different energy
thresholds being
tested, different scale
of the experiments, and
experiments become more
sensitive the larger they are.
And so this you can--
something you can
see from this table.
The next sort of neutrinos
is the ones which
are produced in the atmosphere.
So they are produced in
decays of pions and kaons
and by the cosmic rays
interact with the atmosphere,
or the Earth's atmosphere.
And so you find,
for example, a pi
plus decaying into a
muon and a muon neutrino.
And then the muon
itself can decay
into an electron, an
electron neutrino, and a muon
antineutrino.
So if you, for example, build
a ratio of muon/antimuon over
electron/anti-electron
neutrinos,
you find it should be around 2.
You have two neutrinos--
muon neutrinos here,
and an electron neutrino.
And also, this wasn't
really observed.
And you can see
here, as a function
of the column of the
zenith, of looking up
upwards towards the
atmosphere or downwards,
you find that there is an effect
of this kind of oscillation.
So the actual measurement
depends on the energy range.
And you can see that
the muon neutrinos,
the muon-like neutrinos,
they disappear.
You see here in this very
clear plot the prediction
without oscillation compared
to the experimental results,
so you see the muon
neutrinos actually disappear.
Moving on, accelerators
can be used.
And the big accelerator on the
Earth at CERN or at Fermilab.
The beamline at Fermilab is
called NuMI, Fermilab National
Accelerator Laboratory, FNAL.
Or CERN, or in Japan.
Those are the big sources of
accelerator-driven neutrinos.
And with those, there's big
detectors, typically a detector
very close to the accelerator
and one further away.
The close one probes
the total flux
of the neutrino at the
experiment, and then the one
which is away in order to probe
the effect of the neutrino
oscillation in order to study
appearance or disappearance.
And again here, you see
this is a long program.
But it basically took off quite
a bit in the 2000s and after.
So a lot of neutrino physics
happened in those years.
A lot of information
about the neutrino
was gathered in those years.
And again here-- this is
from the T2K experiment--
you see the comparison between
unoscillated predictions
and oscillated using some
additional constraints
about expectation of the
total flux of the neutrinos,
and that compared to the data.
And you see very
clearly that the--
that the neutrinos
oscillate, that there
is evidence of oscillation.
All right.
The last source are
reactor neutrinos.
We'll talk about nuclear
physics starting from next week.
Here neutrinos are
produced in nuclear fission
of heavy isotopes, mainly
uranium and polonium.
The flux can be calculated
in various ways,
for example by knowing
the nuclear processes
and the thermal power
produced in the reactor,
or by just looking at
how much fuel is being--
nuclear fuel is being used
by the reactor itself.
What's being studied here is
the anti-electron neutrino
disappearance.
And what you do here is you use
this inverse beta decay, where
you have a collision
or scattering
of a anti-electron
neutrino with a proton,
creating an electron-- a
positron and a neutron.
And again, there's a
number of experiments.
Basically, whenever you have
a large neutrino experiment,
it can probe surrounding
nuclear reactors.
There's many of them in France
and Japan, also in China.
And they're being used
in those experiments.
Again, you see that this topic
became really hot in the 2000s.
And again, a lot of--
a lot has been learned.
So this part here shows you
as a function of the energy--
the length over the energy--
so kilometer over meV--
the oscillation, the
survival probability,
meaning that you can actually
see directly the oscillation
of the neutrinos.